yeah let's do it we're here with Hannah
Hart see we we use this is exciting
you're back on the podcast I'm back on
the podcast but I was thinking back to
that I don't remember anything that we
talked about in the first podcast that
we did because it was at the YouTube
space that we shot it and it was like a
year and a half ago yeah all I remember
about that is just how dirty my hair was
that day so every time I think of that
podcast I think of like that gentle
feeling of Filth that you have when
you're like I regret not showering
before coming to this what is there do
you watch reality TV or game shows at
all
um I'm um I'm watching the affair right
now season two that's a scripted series
I don't I really hope that you think
it's a documentary um so sorry I asked
you rushing again do you watch game
shows no no okay have you figured out
your 2016 look no and if any of you
don't know this Hannah Hart has been on
our mission at the end of 2015 into 2016
to figure out what her 2016 look could
you do me a favor and describe to the
audience because I overheard you in
conversation one time describe your 2014
and 2015
look I like to think that I evolved in
style yes we all do every year
absolutely he doesn't 14 was very much
um vests and hats mm don't work together
Hannah best hat tie thing huh huh um she
has fitting was very monochromatic I
went for a lot of just like you know
very simple looks very simple shoes
isn't how you described it before you
really use it 2015 it was like edgy like
I incorporated some more leather into my
look and you said that was such earnest
like conviction but I think whoever is
edgy could it but I that's how I would
describe your 2015 look was edgier like
your hair got lighter and sharper yeah
she's really serious about this 2016
look I just need a look man I don't know
what I'm gonna do is that 16 I think
you're putting a lot of pressure on
yourself to discover a look story my
lash when sometimes looks discover you
know that's not sure you pick what you
want to wear I like what's happening now
it's very casual very laid-back this
this these are my free pile pants that
have a hole in the crotch which is why I
have
below here I forgot it's filmed and then
this sweatshirt which I love which I got
when we were shooting Electra woman and
Dyna girl at each other yeah I love it
um so this is my 2016 look today hey one
day at that PARP arute Oh - OH - wants
to know would you rather stop eating or
talking with your mouth Jesus ting way
to phrase a question you rather be able
to only eat with your mouth or only talk
with your mouth only eat with my mouth
and give up talking forever okay yeah
wow that yeah I think I would do the
same thing that makes them I can write
down all my thoughts great some time
alone to yourself humanity might even
like benefit yeah I'm ready
hi as the producer of your podcast I
have to you just talk for me my 2016
look is Tyler Oakley wants to know in a
food court do you do a lap for samples
or go straight to your spot follow up
favorite food court restaurant i 100% do
a lap for samples of course yeah you
have to just a million percent and I
also want to know what my options are
cuz there's nothing worse than
compromising and settling right and
seeing something you want more down the
road I also fish what the affair is all
about whoa
this episode's sponsored by okay yeah um
yes okay okay so okay